I do tend to subscribe to the idea of
not having or focusing on regrets
because everything we've done sort of
makes us who we are now and I'm happy
with who I am now and especially in
terms of my academic pathway and my
career in physics but if I was to look
back at my undergrad degree in hindsight
there are probably things I would try to
do differently I don't know how they
would affect where I do end up maybe it
would be better maybe it would be worse
but there are probably things I would
try to change so one of them is probably
trying to do more courses in or to do a
minor in computer science so I've spoken
about the importance of coding and
computer science
in terms of physics before but I do
think it is really important and
becoming more so I took some courses in
computer science but not enough for a
minor or a major I instead did my majors
in physics and math it's hard to say
with this one because to have done a
major or a minor in the computer science
as well like I was already taking more
courses than you're supposed to every
semester so I would have had to cut
something out maybe it cut the maths out
and I probably could have done without
the maths since I'm doing an
experimental physics project for my PhD
but I enjoyed the maths all the same in
some ideal situation I would have had
enough room to do the triple major
without adding any more time on to my
degree like another year or another
semester because I didn't want to do
that but yeah I think ideally I would
have done some more of those Comp Sci
courses the second thing I wanted to
talk about was kind of my approach to
studying at University
and it came down to essentially being a
memorization and cramming task for every
exam period at the time this felt like
the best way to get through because we
had so many assignments and so many
courses that I always found myself sort
of disregarding that some of the really
deep connections and and meanings behind
what we were doing and just focused on
how do I get the best grade in the exam
and that really became my focus
especially in exam period and I don't
like that especially in hindsight I look
back and I think I really wish I
actually understood that concept more
even though I got a good grade on it I
don't know like with this it seems to be
almost a systemic thing sort of across
people and across courses that the Uni
system is focused more on outcomes and
grades than it is on your deeper
understanding so I don't know if this
was entirely my fault or just the way
kind of things have to be if you want to
get through it's it's also hard to look
back and say I would change that
approach because I did get good grades
throughout undergrad and if I'd taken
time to really slow down and really
learn I don't know if I would have had
time to do everything that I needed to
do so it's a bit of both but definitely
I look back and I think I probably wish
that I asked more questions more
questions of my friends but also of the
lecturers and enter really trying to
understand deeply the content rather
than being happy with just getting a
good grade on it I think the most common
questions that I ask my friends are just
hey how do you do
question 3 on the assignment
I think now that I'm a PhD student I
have more time to investigate those
deeper learnings and so that's something
I'm trying to do now because in
hindsight I didn't really get the time
to appreciate it as an undergrad I hope
that that helps someone out there and
thanks for watching